aujourd'hui on va se parler de sécurité
en ligne c'est un sujet important et je
sais pas si c'est un sujet qui vous
importe vous mais c'est un sujet qui
devrait vous importez parce que on est
tous en ligne que ce soit sur un mac un
pc que vous ayez un iphone que vous
soyez sur un smartphone android il vous
faut de la sécurité en ligne en 2020
avec le confinement est de plus en plus
de personnes pour passer du temps sur
internet via la plateforme cyber
malveillance point gouv.fr qui a vu sa
fréquentation augmenter de 155% a une ça
en 2020 concernant sont tous nos
tentatives de phishing 17% et de
piratages de comptes 12% et trois
consommateurs français sur cinq se
disent inquiets des cyber risques et
vous avez raison mais vous avez raison
il faut pas rentrer dans la paranoïa on
ne va pas tout savoir des cyberattaques
et compagnie et qu'il faut que c'est
super important club de venir se
prémunir c'est la raison pour laquelle
quand mcafee m'a dit tiens monsieur re
elle tout ça t'intéresse qu'on parle de
cybersécurité on a une nouvelle solution
qui est dédiée aux particuliers et rien
qu'aux particuliers et j'ai trouvé ça
super intéressant parce que à une époque
moi j'utilise un mac on se disait tous
on n'a pas besoin d'antivirus sur notre
mac sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas alors pour autant il
faut pas être paranoïaque mais je pense
qu'il faut venir se protéger alors là je
parle d'antivirus n'ya pas d'antivirus
il ya aussi le fait venir de protéger
son identité en ligne venir protéger
lorsque vous faites des achats en ligne
protéger vos données vérifier qu'il n'y
ait pas des logiciels espions qui
viennent collecter des informations qui
vous appartiennent pour les revendre à
des entreprises que vous donnez ne se
retrouvent pas exposé sur le dark web
que vous ayez un pare-feu qu'on puisse
vérifier ce qui entre et ce qui sort
chez vous sur votre ordinateur enfin
bref il ya plein de poids qui sont hyper
importants et c'est en sac et une
solution qui est intéressante que je
viens vous présenter aujourd'hui en
partenariat avec mcafee s'appelle mcafee
totale sécurité
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'ils font mcafee parce que
chez mcafee ils sont malins et bien ils
viennent surveiller ce qui se passe sur
le dark web voir si vos informations s'y
trouvent si elle s'y trouve ils vous
informent ils vous montrent même le mot
de passe qui a été trouvé et
quelques-uns de mes mots de passe qui
sont sortis un peu anciens mais c'est
pour ça que je fais attention et pouvoir
des mots de passe différents pour avoir
des mots de passe différents et bien des
fois soit vous avez une énorme mémoire
et vous souvenez tous soit vous utilisez
des outils qui vous permettent de gérer
vos mots de passe parce qu'on a
également ici aussi enfin bref c'est
super intéressant est ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on regarde directement
comment ça fonctionne comme ça vous
savez être bienvenue sur mon mac ici
vous avez la solution qui est ouverte
mcafee total protection devant une
petite icône en haut il marqué votre mac
et sécurisé et ça ça me plaît ça c'est
bien qu'ils sont sécurisés et vous avez
la console de protection qui est juste
là alors je vous montre c'est très très
simple qui si c'est l'accueil ça me
montre mon l'état de mon équipement
saint-marc j'ai mon analyse en temps
réel qui activait au niveau de mes virus
donc si à la présence d'un virus ou des
logiciels espions et baffe on me le dit
je vois aussi que j'ai mon pare feu qui
activaient de la même manière toute la
notion de mise à jour qui est aussi
importante à pour me récupérer toutes
les dernières mises à jour et notamment
les bases virales pour venir vous
protège et ça s'est très très bien le
mcafee web advisor alors ça c'est
intéressant aussi si vous arrivez sur un
site vous n'êtes pas sûr avec lui il se
dit ouah pop up ça sent mauvais il va
vous en informer vous partez vous êtes
tranquille bon après vous pouvez venir à
bloquer par catégorie le téléchargement
les sites le phishing bref - ici tout
est activée bloqué par site web si vous
voulez ajouter des sites web à bloquer
directement bout et le faire est
typiquement vous voulez faire des achats
en ligne là on est en période de fin
d'année il va ya voir black friday
d'ailleurs noël peut-être ça la tat on
sait pas bref il va y avoir des achats à
faire et bien c'est quand même rassurant
de se dire que lui il saura vous dire si
c'est ok si vous pouvez y aller si vous
pouvez taper votre numéro de carte ou si
ça craint et puis votre abonnement
bourbon abonnement movelier cours il me
reste encore un petit peu de temps
dessus et ça c'est cool ensuite je peux
venir lancer une analyse analyse
complète une analyse personnalisée c'est
important de bien le faire de temps en
temps quand même vos mises à jour où
vous devez récupérer ici directement
dans votre base virale ça roule le mien
est à jour et puis après vous avez la
sécurité de votre mac alors votre mac si
vous n'avez pas un mac ça fonctionnera
sur un pc analyse en temps réel activé
par feu on revend un peu les choses
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure il ya toute la
question de l'identité qui est aussi
très intéressant ça c'est en ligne
directement sur le site de mcafee va me
donner une note un score et moi je vois
que j'ai un score qui est pas terrible
qui de 460 sur 1000 des alertes retient
votre attention vos informations étaient
dérobées mais nous pouvons vous aider je
vois qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
fuite mot de passe compromis baddou j
allais ya longtemps saubadu plus du tout
aujourd'hui il va ma fiche et le mot de
passe qui était corrompu en tout cas une
partie alors rassurez vous et c'est là
où c'est hyper malin il va vous envoyer
un email avec un code pour vérifier que
c'est bien beau pour vous puissiez voir
une partie du mot de passe donc c'est
hypra hypra hypra sécurisé et une fois
que j'ai traité ça et bien je clique
dessus et j'arrive sur fuites de données
traitées et là je vois que tout a été
traité eh bien ça veut dire que j'ai
changé mes mots de passe et compagnie il
va venir augmenter mon score quand
j'aurai fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire
et donc ça c'est super important et
voyez il y en a un paquet de fuites de
données compilées même son myspace a
c'est un vieux compte aussi j'avais
encore aujourd'hui eh bien il ya le mot
de passe qui a cafouillé et après vous
pouvez venir vérifier d'autres choses
rajouter de gmail à venir à venir
regarder et puis vous avez des
informations à venir surveiller un
passeport numéro fiscal date de
naissance numéro complémentaire santé la
carte bancaire les comptes bancaires
bref tous peuvent venir tout surveiller
et vont voir sur le dark web si vos
infos ils sont et auquel cas ils
regardent image et il vous informe donc
ça c'est quand même vachement rassurant
lorsque vous venez naviguer par exemple
ici sur internet vous allez avoir une
optimisation des performances est ce que
ça va faire typiquement lorsque vous
arrivez sur un site web et ça va bloquer
la lecture de vidéo automatique vous
allez gagner en performance dans votre
machine ça va permettre aussi
d'économiser de la bande passante grâce
à l'optimisation et si vous avez un
problème vous avez accès un support en
ligne et il ya un autre point qui est
super important c'est un gestionnaire de
mots de passe alors regardez le jour
montrent je les ai installés dans chrome
il est ici s'appelle trou qui bâille
mcafee jeu rentrer mon identifiant
paypal jean rampon identifiants facebook
et lui va retenir tous mes mots de passe
ce qui fait que je peux mettre des mots
de passe hyper compliqué avec des
caractères spéciaux minuscules
majuscules beaucoup de lettres beaucoup
de chiffres très très long et lui valait
connaître comme ça ça évitera que vos
mots de passe puisse être captées
deviner très facilement et devenir tout
centraliser si donc ça c'est aussi super
intéressant en plus de ça vous avez un
vpn qui existe un vpn ça fait quoi ça
crée un tunnel cryptées sécurisées entre
vous et la machine distante qui fait
qu'en fait par son dos milieu peut venir
intercepté votre communication alors
deux chez vous c'est vrai qu'à assez peu
de risques à venir utiliser un vpn mais
si vous êtes sur un réseau un hôtel un
agde au réseau d'une ville et compagnie
c'est quand même relativement bien est
important de venir utiliser un vpn le
seul truc avec le vpn c'est qu'il est
disponible sur windows il est disponible
sur l'app store pour votre iphone est
également sur google play bon sur le mac
aujourd'hui tout de suite il n'y a pas
de solution après le côté pratique c'est
qu'il est quand même disponible sur
l'iphone et sur l'ipad ce conseil même
pour le chromebook un garde et un vpn
pour le chromebook ça s'est très très
bien et sur votre mobile eh bien vous
avez la même chose peut venir
télécharger directement pour votre
mobile vous avez également le vpn et
vous le voyez ici fait du monde
numérique un lieu plus sûr pour vos
enfants il ya une protection pour les
enfants grâce à mcafee safe family ça
vous permettra de venir protéger
plusieurs comptes par votre famille mais
également les comptes de vos enfants et
ça c'est cool parce que vous avez
jusqu'à 10 équipements donc si vous avez
une famille de onze enfants vous êtes
mal ou si vous êtes jusqu'à l'iss dans
votre famille ça ira y aura pas de
soucis vous avez ma koffi shredder shr e
d'aidés er raider supprimera les
fichiers sensibles et qui ne laissera
aucune trace donc voyez tout est là pour
votre anonymat et vous avez également
une extension pour votre navigateur ici
c'est safari l'extension de mcafee web
weiser assure une navigation web
sécurisé qu'est ce que ça vient faire
regarder un symbole marquant fait
contenu de la page web peut lire les
données sensibles présente sur les pages
web notamment les mots de passe numéros
téléphone numéro de carte bancaire peut
modifier l'apparence et le comportement
de pages web ceci s'applique sur toutes
les pages web l'idée c'est de venir vous
protège et bien tout simplement l'idée
c'est pas que mcafee regarde ce que vous
faites vous ce match il a été voir s'il
a fait ça n'ont peut voir quand vous
consultez toutes les pages web parce que
oui ils ont accès en fait à votre
navigation complète pourquoi pas pour
bien vous espionner pour faire la verse
pour venir vous protéger c'est une
protection qui est complète vous votre
famille tous vos appareils et la très
très bonne nouvelle là dedans et bien
c'est que je vous offre des licences
enfin c'est pas que moi qui vous offre
ces mcafee et moyens on vous fait cadeau
de licence pour participer c'est très
facile vous avez un lien en bas dans la
description vous cliquez vous tentez
votre chance et c'est peut-être vous
qu'elles aient gagné une des licences de
mcafee total protection pour venir vous
protégez vous et votre famille si une
solution vraiment vraiment pertinente
pour se dire il ya des besoins de
protection n'a besoin de venir se
protéger soi même on a besoin de venir
protéger les siens on a besoin de se
protéger de se prévenir lorsqu'on va
utiliser son numéro de carte bleue sur
internet on a besoin d'un antivirus pour
nous dire ah tiens un truc qui traîne
qui est pas très clean voir ce qui
traîne sur le dark web est ce que vos
infos ont sauté ou pas si vos infos elle
seule sans le dark web c'est pas
forcément vous qui avez fait n'importe
quoi peut-être un site qui a été piraté
avec votre email et votre mot de passe
qui sont sortis moi par exemple il ya
des comptes où je bois qui ajuste mon
email et mon autre famille sont sortis
c'est pas le plus grave plus graves mais
dès qu'il ya un mot de pages de
corrompus et bien il faut bien penser à
changer et si vous faites l'erreur
d'avoir toujours le même mot de passe
comme font beaucoup de personnes et bien
c'est pas la bonne idée vous avez un
outil ici pour gérer tous vos mots de
passe vous mettez donc des mots de passe
forts différents pour tous les sites sur
lesquels vous allez allez et vous allez
voir que votre protection en ligne votre
score il a monté d'un coup et ça va être
super cool donc ça je trouve ça
vachement intéressant j'aime beaucoup
cette solution alors je veux conclure en
vous montrant les tarifs parce que c'est
pas gratuit je pense que vous vous en
douterez rien n'est gratuit dans ce bas
monde mais pour autant c'est pas très
cher vu ce que ça vient faire et vu ce
que ça viens vous apporter comme
solution la joie que la famille et 10
équipement c'est la meilleure offre il
voulut marque 39 euros 95 70 euros de
réduction crois que là globalement pour
à peine 40 balles par an je vais me
protéger c'est pas mal multi équipement
aux cinq appareils je suis à 34,95 pour
un seul équipement je suis un peu moins
de 30 euros très honnêtement si vous
avez une famille vous y allez ça vous
coûte moins de 4 euros par mois ça va
vous êtes quand même relativement
tranquille vous voulez protéger tous vos
appareils vous protéger je dis moi ici
mon mac mais également mon iphone et
comme on est nombreux plus avoir à une
tablette en plus vous protégez vos
femmes ont en tout cas ce qui est mon
cas protéger tous vos appareils avec un
seul et même abonnement et ça c'est bien
et en plus un petit truc qui est là qui
est intéressant c'est garantie de
remboursement sous 30 jours donc si vous
n'êtes pas contents ils vont rendre le
pognon est ce que vous sentez concerné
par tout ces problèmes de sécurité en
ligne est-ce que vous avez un vpn un
antivirus est ce que vous protégez vos
données est ce que vous avez des mots de
passe différents est-ce que vous ça vous
alerte tout ça et est ce que le fait de
regarder cette vidéo vous dit apte que
je suis pas très bon là dessus et qu'il
va falloir améliorer tout ça est une
fois de plus si ça vous intéresse je
vous ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description aller jeter un oeil parce
que la solution est complète et qu'elle
vient abordés je dirais tous les points
de votre sécurité personnelle en ligne
et ça c'est super important sur ce feu
des gros bisous de l'amour vos questions
en bas en commentaire de jean mas les
bisous à plus tard ciao
[Musique]